-Looking good as always, buddy.
Thank you so much
for coming back to the show.
You know we love you here.
-Thanks for having me.
Thank you very much.
It's amazing to be here.
Thank you.
We always have fun.
-If we don't have fun,
we're doing it wrong.
Exactly, buddy.
Yeah, but I have so many things
I want to talk to you about.
First of all, congrats.
You got nominated
for two Latin Grammys.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-With the great Marc Anthony.
-Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
-Marc Anthony.
-Yeah, man.
-How do you guys end up meeting
and knowing each other?
-That was a funny story.
Well, I've been a huge fan
of his music for a long time,
since I was a kid, man.
So, like, my parents,
they actually raised me, like,
listening to Marc Anthony's
songs, right?
So then, one day, I knew
that he wanted to meet me,
and he was living in Miami,
and I was there in Florida, too.
So I received a text,
and that was Marc.
He was saying like, "Yo, bro,
come to hang out to my house."
I was like, "What?
-You're like, "Is this real?"
-Marc.
-Yeah.
-Marc Anthony. Okay, bro.
Let's go. Come on, let's do it.
And then I came to his house,
and we spent -- Wow!
We spent like at least
eight hours talking, man,
like till 4:00 or 5:00 a.m.,
listening to his new songs,
listening to my new songs, like,
back in those days.
And it was amazing, man.
Like, we had these --
-You spent eight hours together?
-Yeah.
-You just hit it off.
-Bro, like, we didn't stop
talking about life
and how our Latin culture,
you know, is impacting
all around the world.
So it's beautiful, man.
You know, like,
having these kind of friends
is always a good idea.
-Yeah, yeah, it's a good idea.
It's good to have -- Especially
a friend like Marc Anthony.
-Yeah, bro. I love him.
He's like a big brother for me.
I love you, Marc.
-He's a legend. He's a legend.
-Yeah, man.
-But then he had you --
You're one of the groomsmen
of his wedding recently.
-It was the first time
that I was having, like,
that role in a wedding.
-Is that Vin Diesel?
-Yeah.
Yo, that's so funny. Look at me.
I'm like, "Yo, I'm here."
-You're like,
"I'm here, too, guys."
-I'm like, "I'm in the back."
Don't leave me."
-You're like,
"Vin, stand in the back.
-I know I'm the youngest.
-Oh, is that David Beckham?
Is this a real photo?
-I think it's Photoshopped,
though.
-It's Photoshopped.
Yeah, okay, good.
-I'm kidding.
-Wait, that's a party
right there.
-Yo, man,
that was a nice party.
[ Laughter ]
For sure. We had a blast, man.
Like, we had so much fun --
-You did?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And is this true that it was
also your birthday, too?
-Yeah.
-While it was his wedding.
-Yeah, that was so weird,
because he called me.
He was like, "Yo, man,
I'm going to have my wedding.
I want you to be part of it."
I was like, "Of course.
But when is it?
Because I'm touring, you know,
and we're always busy.
You're busy, too.
So you have to tell me the date
so I can, you know --"
-Work around it.
-Yeah.
And then he was like,
"January 28th."
"Bro, that's my birthday."
-Any other day, man.
Any other day.
-Like, "Why are you getting
married on my birthday?
Like, can you change it?"
"No, man. Sorry."
-Did you go to the wedding
and pretend
like it was a party for you?
-But it was nice, man,
because I didn't spend
that money,
you know, on my party, so...
-Yeah.
-He paid the cost.
-Another champagne bottle.
For Marc. For Marc.
Let's have
another champagne for Marc.
-He paid my birthday party,
actually.
-Yeah.
Can we talk about "Don Juan"?
-Yes, sir.
-"Don Juan."
Look at this right there.
Now, this -- Did you --
Oh, I know you have tattoos,
but I never saw your back.
Is this --
Did you have this tattoo
before the album or the album --
-You never saw my back?
-No. Usually,
when we hang out at the pool --
-I would be worried, man.
-When we hang out at the pool,
I jump in the pool before you,
so I never see your back.
[ Laughter ]
I would --
By the way, this is a real fact.
I will never take my shirt off
next to you in the rest --
the history of my life.
I don't want to be
near you shirtless.
-No, no, but,
like, we were backstage
and we were saying that --
-I wear Spanx in the pool.
-No, but he's looking, like,
skinny, strong.
Right, guys? Like, he's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
This guy is getting better
every day, like, you know?
-Oh -- But what happens?
This is the album.
You go --
-That's your back.
-Yeah, I got your back.
I got your back, buddy.
-Thank you, man.
-Yeah, no problem.
-Yeah, that's my new album, man.
-Did the album title come first
or did the tattoo come first?
-Hmm.
-I ask the tough,
hard-hitting questions here.
-No, no, no, no, no, no.
The tattoo came first.
Yeah, because I --
Like, I work in the whole idea
and the concept of the album,
you know,
and then I got the tattoo,
because as soon I knew
that I wanted to be like
this character, Don Juan,
for this season
just to call it like that,
then I knew that I had
to get the tattoo.
So, yeah, I work around it
and then I had the tattoo,
and a month later,
I did the cover of the album.
It was kind of painful, though.
Because where did you
get the tattoo?
-That was in Miami.
-Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-That's a beautiful tattoo.
-It's big.
Thank God now,
there's these kind of creams
that they numb you.
Like, they have this numb thing
for the skin,
and you don't feel the pain.
-That's a lot of tattoo.
-That's a lot of ink.
-Yeah, it's a lot of ink.
I don't know -- Yeah.
-You don't have any tattoos?
-I don't have any --
I don't know if I could do it.
I can't commit.
What would I get tattooed --
If I got a tattoo on my back,
what should I put?
-Well...
Okay. Don Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not putting "Don Jimmy."
My back?
-Right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Don Jimmy.
-Don Jimmy and Don Juan,
and then we do a duo.
-We can do a tour together.
-We'll do a duet album.
Yeah, we'll do a duet.
-You know, we switch,
I come do your job.
Then you go to...
-Yeah, that's a deal.
I'll do that with you.
-You go to the Garden.
You perform at the Garden.
-By the way,
Madison Square Garden
tomorrow night.
-Yes, sir. I'm so excited.
-What do you do when you
do these giant things...
[ Cheers and applause ]
You have these giant tours.
What do you do to calm --
Do you, like, go into a room
and meditate and be like...
[ Breathes deeply ]
"Don Juan," you know?
And just like,
"Everyone, leave me alone."
Do you light candles?
What do you do to de-stress?
-Bro, I would say
that I don't have any ritual,
but talking to my family.
You know, like,
it gives me peace.
You know,
also meditating a little bit
and doing just like
5 or 10 minutes.
-Did you always talk
to your family -- always?
-Yeah.
They're now here, actually.
They came for the show.
-They did?
-My parents, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, that's nice.
My whole family came here.
-No way. My dad came to
the show the other night.
It was our first show back.
-Oh, really?
-My dad surprised me,
yeah, and he came to the show.
-How beautiful is that, right?
-It's the greatest.
-It feels great to perform
and see your family there, man.
You know, like,
sometimes, I feel like
I do everything for them,
so it's nice to have them,
you know?
-Yeah. They were there
supporting you from the start.
-Since -- Yeah,
since I started my career.
I was a little crazy kid
when I started, so --
Thanks, parents. Thank you.
-Yeah, thank you, mom and dad.
Yeah.
-Yeah.
-Did I read this right?
Didn't you start almost
as a duo with someone?
-Yeah. Don Jimmy and Don Juan.
-Yes, exactly. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just want a little credit
for your career.
-Yeah, when I started,
I started with another guy.
He's from Colombia, too,
from Medellín.
Hello, Arias.
-Shout-out to Medellín.
-Yeah. Yeah. Thank you.
Yes, sir.
So, this guy came late,
super-late to the studio
the first session that we had.
So I decided to make
my first song by my own.
And then we came to the studio.
We recorded the second song.
But to be honest,
I loved the first one more
than the second one with him.
But -- I don't know -- maybe the
hook was better, you know?
I don't know.
I just love the way
that the song was sounding.
Sorry, bro, I love it,
but without him.
-Yeah. But, no, he went on to
have a great career.
-And now he's a big producer.
He works with Steve Aoki
and he has his own career.
So, Arias...
-Yeah, he's great.
-They've been killin' it, man.
-Everything happens
for a reason.
-Yeah. Yeah. He's killin' it.
-I got to say, you're one of the
hardest-working people I know
and you always do it
the right way
and you crush every time
you come on the show.
But this album
has 25 tracks on it.
-Yeah.
-That's a lot of music.
-Yeah, because I've been
saving a bunch of music
and I didn't want to just
keep it in my files, you know,
because I have so many songs.
And I know that there are,
like, good songs
that deserve to be out.
You know, fans deserve
to have those songs.
So I just didn't want
to keep them with me
and I shared them all, you know?
-But it just came out,
I would say,
at the end of August, maybe,
and then --
-Just a month. Yeah.
-Over a billion streams, buddy.
-Yeah, bro.
Thank you. Thank you.
-Come on!
-Thank you.
-You are crushing it.
-Thank you, bro.
-And your new song,
"Según Quién."
-"Según Quién."
-Yes, sir.
-Which means...
-Guess who. Oh, no, no.
-No, it means
"according to whom?"
-"According to who?" Yeah.
-Yeah.
So, you think
I miss you and I cry?
According to whom?
I don't think so.
-Who told you that
I'm crying because of you?
-You wish.
You wish I was crying over you.
-You want to see me cry.
-You want to see me cry?
According to whom?
-You won't see me crying.
-You're not gonna see me.
-I'm better without you,
actually.
-Exactly. That's another one.
That's right.
"I'm better without you."
That's our first duet?
-Please, but don't do it
over the cover.
-No, no, no. Over here. No.
I'm going to put it
on my lower back.
"Don Jimmy
is better without you."
That's the name of our duet.
-First track. "Don Jimmy."
-You're pointing at me.
You said,
"It's better without you."
[ Laughter ]
-Bro, that was a good one.
-Right?
-"That's better without you."
That's the cover.
-It's the cover.
You're looking at me.
You're like, "Yeah,
the song is better without you."
Yeah, I'll take it.
But you know what made me laugh?
You know, there's a giant
TikTok trend for your song,
and it's because that beat
comes in and goes, "Go, go, go!"
-Boom, boom, boom, boom.
-Yeah.
-And did you start it?
-No, man. Like, this was so fun.
Like, I went into TikTok --
You know, I don't use TikTok
that often, to be honest.
Like, I just like
to put my content there,
but I don't like to be there
all the time,
because, you know, I spend
a lot of time also on Instagram
and all the social media.
So, one day, I was talking
to my team, and they were like,
"Yo, did you see
what the fans are doing
with the song,
with 'Según Quién'?"
And I had no idea.
So I went straight to TikTok
and I saw a girl,
and this girl was doing
something with her hands.
And I was like, "I don't get it.
Like, Is that a trend
or something?
Is that a challenge?"
"Yeah, all these kids
are doing it."
So I started doing it.
And then, right now, on TikTok,
the video has already like
40 million views, man.
-No, everyone's doing it
'cause they're doing it
because they're just going like,
"Hey, I don't cry.
Who told you that I cried?"
And she goes, knock
and then backwards knock,
but a finger is lifted,
but it's not this finger.
-This one.
-It's not that one either.
It's everything --
every other finger but that one.
[ Laughter ]
It's every -- I'm sorry.
I get so silly when
you're on the show every time.
But it goes one, two, three...
-Boom. Yeah.
-And it is really fun.
If you just check out --
Search for Maluma on TikTok.
It is the thing
that's trending right now.
And you're doing
that song for us tonight.
Who produced that track,
by the way?
-Edgar Barrera and Keityn --
Mexico and Colombia.
These guys, they are Latinos
and they're killing the game,
so shout-out to Keityn, Edgar.
-That is a great sound.
It is a different sound.
It's so good.
-The whole crew, guys.
-Congratulations on this.
-Thank you.
-You're singing for us later.
You know I love you, buddy.
And break a leg
at the Garden tomorrow.
-Thank you.
-Maluma!
"Don Juan" is available now.
He'll be performing
for us later in the show.
Hayley Williams joins us
after the break.
Stick around. Come on back.
♪♪